So usually around this time after each
night
we would have a you know short or a few
words of advice from the Quran
However,
tonight, alhamdulillah, we are here to
introduce myself to you, for you to
introduce yourselves to me as kind of a
welcoming
kind of gathering.
And so, seeing as that is the case,
inshallah, we will have our gathering in
the gymnasium after the
As was mentioned with some tea and
sweets and so forth, all are invited.
I'd to take this opportunity to
thank everyone for their very warm
welcome, all of the hospitality. I'm
very happy to be here. I'm actually very
excited and optimistic about what the
future holds for us inshallah together
as a community. And I feel very
blessed to be here.
[Silence]
Oh, one more thing that I forgot to say.
I got to say it. Somebody's parked in my
parking spot outside. , it's a
MercedesBenz.
There's a big sign. It says, you know,
reserved for the me. So, if that's you,
please move your car. I had to park up
the street. So,